one tweet is putting at risk the NBA's
multibillion-dollar opportunity in China
while upsetting basketball fans at home
and abroad
it was sparked when Houston Rockets
general manager Daryl Morey tweeted his
support for Hong Kong protesters the NBA
stands out from other US companies and
that it didn't count out to China's
pressure whereas other companies have
they'll say sorry
they'll express regret at what's
happened the idea is for them to get
their relationships with the Chinese
what's been interesting with the NBA is
this backlash from American consumers
has made that much more difficult for
them this dilemma is heightened even
more as China could overtake the US as
the world's largest retail market as
soon as this year so can US brands
reconcile its values and Chinese money
the Houston Rockets are one of the most
popular NBA teams in China Chinese
basketball legend Yao Ming spent his
entire NBA career in Houston a lot of
American companies have made a really
big deal out of China in the past few
years it's they're sort of premier
growth markets where they see a lot of
their expansion in the coming years
today China has 300 million basketball
players nearly as many people as there
are in the u.s. in July Chinese tech
giant $0.10 which is the official
broadcaster of NBA games paid at least
1.5 billion dollars to extend its
streaming deal with the lead the team
tried to distance themselves from Maury
who said he didn't mean to offend anyone
but the damage was done billions of
dollars are now at stake Chinese company
sponsors and the Chinese Basketball
Association suspended ties with the
Rockets the national TV broadcaster
decided to not air two upcoming NBA
games and said it would reconsider its
partnership with the league 10 cent
reported that 490 million Chinese people
had watched an NBA basketball game last
year that's a huge deal the NBA's
initial response called Maurice tweet
regrettable but Thatcher's Swift
criticism from US politicians on both
sides of the aisle
[Music]
the usual way that US companies navigate
through and this is true companies
outside the US as well is to give it
effectively
they'll apologize or back down and
whatever way they can without breaking
laws in their home country in June
Nike withdrew a shoe collection in China
after its co designer brand supported
the Hong Kong protesters demand to kill
an extradition bill that sparked the
protests the luxury retailer tiffany
apologized for a tweet that Chinese
netizens saw as Pro Hong Kong covering
the right eye has become a symbol of
police brutality after a woman was shot
in the eye by police the NBA took a
different stance we are not apologizing
for Darrell exercising his freedom of
expression there facing is the
difficulty between the US base of
consumers you don't really want them to
apologize for expressing an opinion on
Hong Kong against their new Chinese
consumers they've faced a clash between
the two groups the NBA is discovering
that it's impossible to have it both
ways the least strong brand in the US
could be tarnished if its executives are
seen to be in Beijing's pocket I think
it's going to be completely impossible
to avoid these scandals completely
essentially it's balancing that the
freedom of speech of your employees and
the people associated with your company
against what Beijing wants in your
fastest growing growth market